leaving to nasik we met on a reading
game I see it felt like I knew her yeah
your category right here on yeah well we
met on Craigslist I was pressed out of
jail she was pretty out of jail I
actually met her to her husband so I
just DM her and said hey if this quake
kills us just kind of a crush on you
I saw her for the first time on my
wedding night
yeah so leave it an Austrian met on her
wedding game although we've engaged for
like a few months before we got married
I wasn't allowed to meet her because her
family was very conservative so I said
okay I trust my parents so whatever they
decide I could accept it did turn out
quite well we've been married for 33
years very happily and her best friend
and I think I'm her best friend we have
three kids all gonna and if they're not
quite well well we're your thoughts when
you saw each other for the first time on
your wedding night
the first thought was that he could be
my best friend we can understand
I was happy to see him talk to him
it's also good experience because a big
gamble very risky
but I was open to all kinds of
possibilities so well as I mentioned
we're from France and we're both actors
and we met on set and I want to film we
were supposed to be a couple and hope
you liked it how long have you guys been
together now for years I actually met
her - her husband so her ex-husband was
your friend yeah how did he take it
actually he was actually really cool but
we both have a mutual respect for each
other it's all great there is no rules
in love and war right
how long have you guys been together for
about a year just under a year a year
next month October 13 we met in the
cafeteria it's about a year and a half
ago and we somehow took a long journey
of getting here
today's your birthday yes can you kind
of explain why the journey was long and
what it took to get here
so do you wanna say - I mean - I had a
boyfriend
and then and then I didn't have a
boyfriend then he went to you to London
and then he came back and then I went to
Spain so she did that trying to avoid me
actually so this is like the first time
we've actually been together but he's my
friend
yeah so we talked I'm your friend
I said he is you're still my friend it's
not like but yeah so we made it here
finally
can you guys each take a turn answering
the next question why did you want to go
on a date ladies first
yes okay so he's super nice and sweet
and honestly I just hate fake
tries really hard gosh no no that's like
this one good thing it just means you
put in effort and that's really like
impressive she caught my eye when we
first met in the cafeteria about a year
and a half ago I first noticed how
beautiful she is and yeah how beautiful
she is in her heart I loved her heart
I think she's incredibly interesting
in so many ways I love being around her
yeah and we've been around each other a
lot in the past couple weeks so yes I
saw this handsome young man and he came
up to me and he's dead
excuse me but don't I know you you look
familiar
and all of a sudden he did look familiar
he looked like my neighbor I grew up
with a little Billy Erwin and
unfortunately I said oh my god you're
Little Billy er no no no he goes no and
then I go well I guess I don't know you
so I walked up so he came up another
aisle and bumped into my cart he goes it
was a line and I go you mean you lied
I've never seen you before in my life
but you look really nice and I was so
excited that I whipped out my deposit
slip that my girlfriend and told me to
do because it has all the information
and I said this is so exciting here's my
deposit he said let him I want to have
for like over it's got my name I just
was a total idiot then I was just so
excited so that's how we met last week
like 40 years ago
so actually we were both in an
alternative custody facility markayla
work furlough I was fresh out of jail
she was fresh out of jail and there's
just something draw me towards her
I decided to walk up and the
conversation that we started that's
pretty much won or over instantly was I
brought up the meter triangle yeah and I
kind of played stupid a little bit I
didn't know what it was made for still
really smart
major laughter I saw there is like an
instant connection
yeah I love that first sight how long
have you guys been together almost a
month and many more County
we met on OkCupid OkCupid Danny an ultra
by Facebook we met through MySpace
well we met on Craigslist I post it
actually I posted on strictly platonic
you I pay you drive I didn't have my car
and I just got paid so I just wanted to
go for dinner and he responded but I
decided it was too late that night and
so I posted again the same thing the
next morning see replay it again
I know that that's how it started about
nine years ago
and then we just got married five years
ago and just had our Jimmy twelve weeks
ago so were you scared at all meeting
someone on Craigslist no I have rules
um you bring your own money and you make
sure your phone is charged and I would
like to say we met at a public place but
he actually came to where I was living
and met there I think I was just stupid
it worked and we actually met through
twitch the streaming platform yes so I
came across his channel through a mutual
friend and we got talking and I
commissioned him to do some work for me
and you know we never still talking's
and son yeah yeah a year and a half
later now yeah yeah we decided we will
come live a pass on from the UK and I'm
from outside Chicago oh yeah you're
capturing right here on camera it's
phenomenal at least I went to high
school with my brother for a couple
years and we just follow each other on
social media and there were some
earthquakes a little north
of La actually a wild North LA and so I
felt them and I tweeted about it and she
liked all my tweets and you know you
always thinking about the big one so
it's kind of scary so I just DM de and
said hey if this quake kills us just
kind of let you know crush on you and
here we are
so we met okay yeah we were in seventh
grade we have the same history teacher
mr. hazel together so that is where we
first originally met and it just like
slowly kind of graduated on and then
when we got out of high school we ended
up meeting again and like a weird sense
and we were traveling festivals and
stuff together and then we just finally
rekindled he's very caring and he treats
me very well and I love that and he's my
my other half that I've missed it's my
twin flame when we were 16 he messaged
me on MySpace and we're 33 no yeah and
we never met up he lived super far away
ten years went by and the whole time
when we turned 21 we had similar friends
so we would see each other at out at
events and stuff and we would always
wave hi to each other but we never
shared a conversation we just like
acknowledged like hey I know you from
MySpace like hey you're that weird guy
that messaged me on MySpace into the end
literally ten years went by I was single
finally and he was 2 and then he
messaged me on Facebook but then I was
like will you help me find a normal guy
and a healthy find a normal girl as a
joke and then he was like oh you're
single no no like yeah and he's like
well I've got a normal which was an
utter total lie cuz he's not normal at
all we had plans to hang out on a
Wednesday I was like whatever I'm single
yeah I'll come over
and we ended up hanging out till like
4:00 in the morning we literally hung
out every single day from that day until
five months into our relationship when I
went to Las Vegas with my girlfriend and
we've been together ever since in seven
years we just got back from getting
married over the weekend like three days
ago your relationship lasted from
MySpace honestly from yous like the
first kind of hung out with her just the
connection
I literally just felt like from the
moment
I knew from the first day I really
didn't know that it could be something
good but it actually wasn't till about
six months into our relationship when we
had some pretty bad hardships every
other time that's ever happened in my
life I pretty much ran or been like oh
this is done but even though it was the
worst thing in the world there was zero
part of me that ever thought that
leaving was an option and I've never
felt like that in my life
and pretty much no matter what happens
with us as hard and as crazy as things
get like him not being my life really is
never an option which is kind of crazy
you
every one before you go ice wanna let
you know that I put together a playlist
of episodes similar to the one you just
watched
so if you liked this episode make sure
to check that out it'll be linked
somewhere on the screen I also just want
to thank you guys for everything it's
pretty crazy how far we've come in just
two years and I can't believe I get to
do this every week you know it's a it's
a lot of fun making these episodes but
most of the fun is and getting to share
it with you guys because you guys are
just the coolest and I love hearing what
you have to say about each episode yeah
I can't thank you guys enough so thank
you again that's pretty much it I'll see
you guys next week
[Music]
you